جره اخرى لا تلتزم بمبادئ حزن الجوار
والذريعه دائما الاحزاب الكرديه وهي تركيه
نقاط التفتيش التركيه تنتشر في نحو الفا
و53 كلم مربعا من اراضي شمال العراق اين
نحن ثلاثه فاصله خمسه في المئه من مساحه
اقليم كردستان ومؤخرا تعد الامر حدود
الاقليم وسعد تركيا للطاقه ضربتها
بطائراتها المسيره ونفذ الضرب على عمق 281
كم داخل الحدود العراقيه مستهدفه خاضعه
للسلطه الحاديه سنجار والموصل الامثله في
خطوه استفزازيه نشرت مديريه الاتصالات
التركيه خارطه عام 2020 اظهرت القواعد
العسكريه الرسميه للقوات التركيه في شمال
العراق
نشرنا فقه هجوم كبير
لتزيل انقره الخريطه وازاله الخريطه
رياضيا عم لكن الواقع لا يزال كما هو اكثر
من 10,000 جندي تركي في العراق بحسب
النسخه التركيه من صحيفه الاندباندا
البريطانيه ولان الجنود يحتاجون للاوامر
يزورهم من فتره لاخرى وزير الدفاع التركي
وكمان نشاهد هي زيارات دون اختار السلطات
العراقيه بل وعدم الاكتراف باحتجاجات
بغداد المستمره رغم ان بين تركيا وايران
قاسم المشترك وهو انتهاك سياده العراق
لكنه تمت خلافات شركاء طهران في العراق
يظهرون ظهرهم الانتهاكات ايران وينتقدون
هجمات تركيا